[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con hoy
hablaremos con la ganadora del premio
reportaje de ref y radio francia
internacional en español que se dirige a
los estudiantes en periodismo de menos
de 30 años que cursan estudios en
américa latina y el caribe
alejandra parra es la ganadora de la
edición 2021 ella ganó con el trabajo
denominado cuerpo sin patria un
reportaje de gran fuerza emocional sobre
la labor de una ong que da sepultura a
centenares de migrantes venezolanos
anónimos que han muerto cruzando la
frontera entre venezuela y colombia o
han sido asesinados por traficantes de
personas y bandas criminales gracias a
alejandra por estar aquí con nosotros en
france 24 y felicidades a usted como
venezolano en colombia que le supuso
personalmente hacer un reportaje sobre
la muerte de compatriotas en su intento
de emigrar hacia este país hacia
colombia
bueno es una historia que es
relativamente familiar conozco
muchísimos miembros de mi familia que
han tenido que cruzar de esta forma
familiares directos precisamente en el
cruce por la guajira
lo que significaba que habían cosas que
yo conocía que algunos compañeros míos y
estudiantes de periodismo nunca habían
escuchado o entendían como una historia
que se les contaba estén solo en medios
y se les contaba a mi parecer un poco
incompleta porque ahorita la migración
venezolana en colombia se expresa de una
forma muy específica y es estadística es
basada en la criminalidad y es basada en
el riesgo que supone que lleguen más
venezolanos a colombia sí pero no
necesariamente que está ocurriendo que
en la mitad de ese proceso pone en
riesgo a los implicados
ahora con qué dificultades encontró
usted en la realización de ese trabajo
creo que lo más difícil es lograr que en
un espacio tan violento
las fuentes confíen en uno lo suficiente
como para poder contar cosas tan
profundas y tan íntimas como esto me
pasó hace menos de seis meses cruzando
de esta forma que pues fue el caso de la
fuente que yo llamé javier no porque da
mucho miedo son espacios en los que
tienen que seguir habitando después de
que yo me voy terminó mi investigación
entonces lo más difícil es lograr esa
confianza es en ese punto inicial en
donde dicen te voy a contar esto que no
me gustó que fue violento que me ocurrió
cómo lograste esa confianza con la gente
que trabajaste y como además recibió a
tus amigos y tu alrededor
este este mensaje que quería mostrarle
de la realidad de la migración
venezolana
como logré esa confianza bueno este creo
que tengo muy a mi favor que yo soy muy
orgullosa de donde nací entonces
hablando con una de mis fuentes yo
estaba pues comentándole un poco sobre
mí antes para poder como crear esa
sensación de que supiera quién soy yo y
me llevé la sorpresa de que esta persona
conocía la historia de mi familia porque
nosotros somos de la zona de la guajira
pero con venezuela éste somos del zulia
en maracaibo y precisamente ya conocían
a mi familia y con eso fue como el golpe
de ok este qué curioso me quieren contar
cosas también porque recuerdan a mi
familia a mis este pésame abuela mis
abuelos y ya eso cómo rompió eso y
precisamente por eso creo que cuando
lo pude detener completamente editado y
ya se lo estaba mostrando a la gente a
mi alrededor
pues creo que toca a muchas personas en
mi familia porque ahorita solo está una
persona de toda mi familia somos una
familia súper grande en venezuela
y si fue como hoy yo recuerdo haber
cruzado ahí y me pasó esto y esto y lo
otro si yo recuerdo tener que cruzar de
esta forma y fue súper difícil fue super
traumático
y oyes y mira que yo nunca he leído esta
parte de la historia no sé qué pasa si
morimos ahí
fuerte alejandra lo que pasa con la
migración venezolana que intenta buscar
una vida mejor en países como colombia
incluso pasando hacia eeuu por
centroamérica y méxico gracias por su
tiempo por estar aquí con nosotros en
france 24 estábamos conversando con
alejandra parra ganadora del premio
reportaje de rf en español hasta aquí
cinco minutos con continúe con nosotros
son muy buen día